hey guys it is October the 19th today my
name is Jess and you're watching games
but news report has suggested that had a
Okajima has left Konami and Kojima
Productions a source indicated to the
New Yorker that Kojima parted ways with
the company earlier this month on
october nine the sauce in question
reportedly attended a departure ceremony
for the veteran game developer on that
day gamespot has contacted Konami for
confirmation The New Yorker added that
Kojima has a non-compete clause that
expires in December which would indicate
that he'd need to wait until then to
sign on with another company 343
industries have announced the file size
for halo 5 Guardians as well as the
details of its day one patch according
to game informer halo 5 will take up
about 55 gigabytes of hard drive space
as for the update executive producer
josh holmes explained on twitter that
the day one update which pertains to the
game's multiplayer will be 9 gigabytes
as for what in it's always been told is
that it has something to do with
multiplayer map content if you're
pre-loading your copy you'll also be
able to install the day one update prior
to launch so long as you're using the
xbox one instant on load and finally in
an interview with PlayStation Magazine
uncharted co-director Neil druckmann has
talked about this series coming to a
close drachman said we get more and more
that feeling of this definitely being
the end of an era for us as a studio
we've been with this franchise for
almost 10 years now from inception all
the way to this point drachman added
that he and director Bruce Straley opted
to change the story of Uncharted
significantly when they were brought on
after Amy headaches departure uncharted
4 will be the final entry in the series
to Starling great although you may not
have seen the last of him since the
movie is in the works let me know down
in the comments if you'd like to see the
Uncharted series continue on without me
and Drake you can add to gamespot or
we've got stories on it all out for Xbox
one controller and a new star wars
battlefront trailer that is everything I
have
day as always let me know what matter to
you and I will catch you same time
tomorrow